It's a tablet PC with a split personality.
Taiwan's ViewSonic has developed a tablet that runs Android 2.2 and Windows 7 Professional.
And it's showing it this week at the Computex IT Show in Taipei.
Tablets running both operating systems have already been developed,...
...including a model from ViewSonic.
But this computer brings something new.
Typically including our predecessor, our 10 series,...
...you get to switch between the two OS but you need to do it from the boot up screen.
But this one, we have advanced that technology into something that with one touch of a button,...
...then you can switch between the two OS.
ViewSonic expects buyers to use Windows primarily for work...
...because of the greater number of business applications available on that platform.
As a business user, you need both with a Windows environment,...
...at the same time you're concerned about battery life.
So, the concept of ViewPad 10Pro comes from; we want to take advantage of both worlds:...
...the Windows world and also the Android world.
Running Android uses less power than running Windows according to the company.
The computer is based on Oak Trail, Intel's newest Atom processor,...
...which should also bring power savings over previous Atom processors.
The device will be priced between $699 and $799 when it goes on sale in Taiwan later this month.
ViewSonic has yet to decide if it will put it on sale overseas.
At Computex 2011 in Taipei, this is Martin Williams, IDG News Service.